hola hoy vamos a hablar de un superpoder
al que muchos de nosotros aspiramos si
el superpoder de innovar y para empezar
les voy a presentar lo último en
tecnología que es esta pequeña pastilla
con esta pastilla yo voy a adquirir el
poder de leer la mente de las personas
ahora puedo hacer un ejercicio si la
mayoría de ustedes mujeres todavía están
pensando en lo increíble y asombrosa e
inspiradora que fue la plática anterior
si de este lado todavía están pensando
que seguramente esa pastilla no sirve a
lo largo de la plática veremos algunos
otros ejemplos en los que vamos a
descubrir cómo es que este superpoder
puede ayudarnos a innovar
pero qué pasa si yo no focalizó este
superpoder qué pasa si yo intento leer
la mente de una persona que sólo habla
mandarín mi superpoder quedará en ceros
yo no esté estaré generando valor ni
ningún beneficio a mi entorno y esto es
algo que pasa mucho alrededor de la
innovación hoy en día muchas empresas
muchas personas intentan innovar y
fallan en el proceso y una de las
razones principales es que nosotros nos
focalizamos ese beneficio que queremos
lograr para nuestro entorno
otro ejemplo bastante famoso es la
tetera de carelman si nosotros la vemos
podemos observar un diseño bastante
agradable bonito a la vista muchos de
nosotros podríamos pensar en comprarla
pero si miramos más a detalle podremos
ver que la funcionalidad de esta tetera
es básicamente nula si ustedes intentan
servirte con esto van a fallar hoy en
día el 70 por ciento de las iniciativas
de transformación digital fracasan justo
porque las personas generan ideas y
estas ideas se quedan como tal y no
terminan ejecutándose como una
iniciativa o un beneficio para nuestro
entorno
primero vamos a entender qué es
creatividad creatividad es la capacidad
de generar una idea sí ya sea que esta
idea se ejecute o no si podemos ser
creativos al pensar o elucubrar un
superpoder podemos ser creativos al
pensar en llevar el hombre al hombre a
marte
podemos ser creativos al imaginar un
robot que con reconocimiento facial
aprenda a clasificar las emociones
humanas y que con base en nuestros
sentimientos nos pueda recomendar una
fruta suena chistoso suena trivial pero
son cosas que están ocurriendo hoy en
día
continuando los vamos a definir qué es
innovación la innovación es justo la
capacidad de ejecutar estas ideas y
cambiar nuestro entorno con creatividad
vamos a tener una tetera de carelman o
un superpoder inútil con innovación
vamos a lograr cambiar nuestro entorno
qué pasa hoy en día si yo tengo ganas de
comprar unos tenis voy a google
busco unos tenis azules veo algunos
resultados visitó algunas páginas voy a
hacerles una pregunta qué pasa 5
segundos después de que yo comencé mi
búsqueda por estos tenis en internet con
mi superpoder puedo saber que todo se
está empezando así que si yo voy a
instagram o voy a facebook o alguna otra
red social de las primeras cosas que voy
a encontrar es una oferta una promoción
o alguna página de tenis sí qué pasa hoy
en día las empresas las grandes marcas
desarrollaron y adquirieron el poder de
leer nuestras mentes apalancando datos
apalancando tecnología las nuevas
tendencias inteligencia artificial big
data la nube el internet de las cosas si
nosotros después de esto vamos a la
tienda seguramente vamos a recibir una
notificación o un mensaje
gustavo sabemos que estás buscando unos
tenis y solo por hoy te vamos a hacer
una promoción sí 20 descuento en los
tenis que estás interesado y es la
primera vez que yo incluso visitó esa
tienda otra vez que es lo que ustedes
harían con esto simplemente va a ser
comprarlos
esto tiene un precio seguramente muchos
de ustedes estarán pensando la mayoría
seguramente vio de social dilema no
marca un precio y solamente una cara de
la moneda que es justo el costo de la
privacidad que pasa cuando dejamos que
las empresas moneticen nuestros datos y
nos controlen esto es el lo que busca
marcar este documental pero sólo se
marca una cara de la moneda
yo quiero que ustedes vean la otra que
pasa cuando nosotros vamos al doctor hoy
en día si se tiene un buen registro si
se tiene un buen se tiene bien
documentados nuestros comportamientos de
consumo nuestros patrones de
comportamiento los diagnósticos van a
ser mucho más asertivos y hoy en día se
están salvando miles de vidas gracias a
los datos gracias a la inteligencia
artificial que es algo que no nos
muestra de su ser del bien
d'alema
de hecho uno de los algoritmos de
inteligencia artificial que es más usado
hoy en día se llama árboles de decisión
éste nació en los submarinos de liu es
navy y se popularizó en un hospital de
chicago justo con el único motivo de
ayudar a las enfermeras ya los doctores
a clasificar los ataques al corazón de
una manera mucho más eficiente si hoy en
día existen algoritmos de inteligencia
artificial que con base en muchos datos
van a estar ayudando a médicos a
clasificar el cáncer de sus pacientes a
dar tratamientos mucho más asertivos si
hoy en día nosotros vamos a encontrar
que si dejamos que exploten nuestros
datos si si sacrificamos un poco de esa
privacidad nuestra experiencia como
clientes va a subir vamos a recibir
ofertas y nosotros queríamos ir a cancún
seguramente en vuelos incluso vamos a
poder salvar nuestras vidas o de las
personas que nos rodean cuando dejamos
que se apalanque la tecnología
hoy en día incluso hay algoritmos que
pueden pronosticar y predecir la
depresión de una persona solamente al
ver su perfil en instagram
entonces qué es esto que nosotros
queremos lograr si es este beneficio
para que ustedes y las personas y
nuestro entorno cambie y mejore y no
solamente nos quedemos con un robot que
recomienda frutas con base en nuestro
estado de ánimo
como llegamos al día de hoy si al día de
hoy tenemos eventos que han cambiado y
han trascendido a través de la historia
y tenemos disrupciones como los coches
el teléfono el internet los aviones los
viajes al espacio del otro lado
tenemos a los disruptores tenemos
cientos walt disney
jeff bezos tesla elon moscú entre muchos
otros
pero lo que nadie nos dice es que en
realidad para ser innovadores no
necesitamos un superpoder para ser
disruptivos no sé no necesariamente
tenemos que generar o crear un robot que
pueda recomendar frutas con base en
reconocimiento facial para cambiar al
mundo no necesitamos llevar al humano
marc para cambiar el mundo
necesitamos fijarnos en todas esas
pequeñas cosas que nos rodean en nuestro
día a día
en realidad el concepto de silla tiene
cientos incluso miles de años
y alguien pensó
y ponerle ruedas solamente el simple
hecho de ponerle ruedas a esa silla
ayudó a mejorar la calidad de vida de
cientos de miles de personas en el mundo
si el concepto de ponerle ruedas a una
canasta y hacerla más grande para hacer
nuestro super no es nuevo tiene 80 años
sin cambiar y el carrito de super
facilita la vida de las personas las
plumas byc como las conocemos tienen más
de 80 años sin cambiar el concepto y lo
que todos ustedes usan hoy en día y
conocemos como cuchara tiene más de 300
años sin cambiar su diseño
entonces vamos a partir en cómo innovar
si vamos a partir en cinco sencillos
pasos que ustedes pueden seguir a la
hora de que ustedes quieran generar una
nueva iniciativa
nosotros número uno vamos a dejar que la
tecnología entre a nuestras vidas vamos
a lograr abrazar la tecnología apalancar
estas tendencias para nosotros lograr en
entrar en este mundo y lograr este tipo
de cambios
después vamos a definir un beneficio que
ustedes tienen que tener bien focalizado
que es lo que ustedes quieren lograr no
solamente van a crear una tetera no
solamente van a adquirir un superpoder
ustedes tienen que buscar qué es lo que
eso va a lograr para las personas que
los rodean o para ustedes mismos
qué pasa si dentro de nuestra empresa o
donde trabajamos tenemos más de una idea
que nosotros queremos ejecutar y esta es
una pequeña gráfica que ustedes pueden
usar para mapear las diferentes
iniciativas que ustedes tengan del lado
superior izquierdo vamos a tener los
unicornios si son iniciativas que
requieren poco tiempo o un grado bajo de
complejidad y al mismo tiempo nos van a
dar mucho valor los llamamos unicornios
porque son raros y difíciles de
encontrar después vamos a continuar con
el cuadrante de abajo a la izquierda los
quit queens otra vez iniciativas de poco
tiempo y poca complejidad pero igual y
no tanto valor estas iniciativas nos
ayudan a generar experiencia nos ayudan
a generar esa bola de nieve que nosotros
vamos a continuar si ya sean recursos ya
sea cualquier tipo de atracción que
nuestras iniciativas vayan a generar
para eventualmente nosotros poder
ejecutar
las iniciativas de largo plazo requieren
un poco más de complejidad
seguramente requieren un poco más de
experiencia y requieren mucho tiempo
pero vamos a estar apalancando una
cantidad de experiencia y beneficios o
recursos que vamos a haber generado con
las primeras que nos van a permitir
lograr ejecutar estas por último vamos a
tener la zona de peligro si bien son
iniciativas o ideas que nos van a ayudar
a generar un impacto
están en la zona de peligro porque si
iniciamos con ese tipo de iniciativas
podemos fallar debido a falta de
experiencia falta de recursos a falta de
haber recorrido ese generar una idea y
ejecutarlas para innovar
número 3 diseñar de una manera asertiva
si hay muchas metodologías hay muchas
tendencias hoy en día en torno a diseño
design thinking entre muchas otras que
lo que nos dicen es tú puedes generar
una idea muy valiosa pero tienes que
focalizar lo que sea que estás haciendo
en tu cliente si en ese beneficio que tú
te quieres generar es donde tú vas a
centrar todo tu desarrollo desde la
construcción de la idea hasta la
ejecución
número 4 vamos a desarrollar de una
manera ágil si hay metodologías como lin
como haya el diferentes metodologías que
nos ayudan a entender cómo recorrer ese
camino de una manera más sencilla y que
los tropiezos que tengamos porque vamos
a tener tropiezos nos ayuden a aprender
a pilotear para que al final tengamos
algo un producto un servicio o una
experiencia que nosotros queremos
generar que de verdad aporte valor para
las personas que van a intelecto
interactuar con ellos
ahora si les dijera que no van a fallar
que esta fórmula es infalible yo les
estaría mintiendo la verdad es que en
estas aventuras en estas jornadas de la
innovación emprendimiento se va a fallar
lo que necesitamos hacer es que si vamos
a fallar fallamos rápido sí que
capitalicemos ese conocimiento esa
experiencia que nosotros estamos
generando al fallar y podamos apalancar
lo para pivotear y crecer
por último me gustaría dejarles una
parte de esto si estaré contradiciendo a
muchas personas que se han parado en
diferentes foros a decir que las ideas
generan valor la verdad es que una idea
por sí sola no genera valor
yo puedo pararme aquí y empezar a hacer
una lista de ideas de superpoderes de
viajes al espacio coches voladores
cualquier cantidad de cosas e ideas que
tanto yo como ustedes podemos estar
generando pero por sí sola una idea no
va a generar valor nosotros tenemos que
llevarla a cabo nosotros tenemos que
ejecutarla y ejecutarla con ese
beneficio en mente por último me
gustaría invitarlos
a cuestionar su alrededor cuestión en su
día a día porque yo hago esto porque mi
rutina se compone de esto para que así
ustedes puedan cambiar su mundo muchas
veces
[Aplausos]